We've got... All of that divided by
4xy
There are several ways to think about them, they're all equivalent
This is going to be the exact same thing. We can esssentialy sort of separate the numerators.
This is the same thing as...
And there's multiple ways to think about it.
One is: If I have a+b over c
this is clearly the same thing as a over c plus b over c
we're just adding the--we're taking the fraction apart.
If we did it in reverse, we'd just be adding fractions
Another way to think about it is
We're distributing the division.
We're dividing the whole thing by 4xy
so we divide each of the terms by 4xy.
The last way to think about it, which is really the same thing,
is that we're multiplying the whole thing by 1 over 4xy
So we're distributing the 1 over 4xy times everything
which is the same as dividing by 4xy.
Either way we get to this and we just have to simplify this
really just using exponent properties.
So we can divide 12. 12 divided by 4 is pretty straight forward
that is just 3, so let me just write it this way.
So 12 divided by 4 is 3. And x squared
divided by x. Remember x is the same thing as x to the first power,
so thats going to be x to the three minus two
Sorry, x to the three minus one power.
Which would be x squared. And finally
you have y to the third divided by y.
Well thats just divided by y to the one.
and y to the third divided by y to the one is going to be y squared.
Three minus one is two.
Now lets do the next term.
Plus, we have sixteen over 4, which is just four.
That is just equal to four. Then we have x to the fourth over
x. Well, once again, x is just the same thing as x to the first
So this is going to be x to the four minus one or x to the third power.
And then finally, we have y divided by y.
Well, thats just going to be one.
So we don't even have to write it down. We could right one here,
but that wont do much, won't change the values.
So just these guys essentially cancel out. And then finally you have
ten divided by 4. they're both divisible by two, so it becomes five halves.
So that part over there simplifies to five over two.
So, plus five halves and then x divided by x.
Those just cancel out, so thats just one.
y divided by y, thats just one as well.
So we're left with five halves.
And we're done!
This whole expression simplified to...